author and columnist mark Stein joins us
tonight to break down what exactly is
going on so at some point do you think
the conversation becomes why would
someone want to kill strangers why are
an increasing number of people wanting
to kill strangers why are we having that
conversation because I think the the
people who run not only Canada but the
entire Western world now don't want to
admit that they no longer have control
of the situation yeah this this part of
Toronto which happens to be my hometown
I was in this neighborhood a couple of
weeks ago for a bar mitzvah all the
streets have English names the the the
school is named after Field Marshal Lord
Haig who commanded British forces during
the Great War
they've got streets called princess and
Empress and there's one named after Lord
Bing who was Governor General of Canada
you can't find anybody with names like
that in that neighborhood now it's
become largely Chinese Korean there's
some Iranians there's Moroccan Jews and
in this case it's somebody with an
Armenian name and if you look on a
society as just like one big stamp
collection and it's nice to have one of
everything then then the modern Western
city is a great place but in these
multicultural hotpots
grievances develop regardless of whether
it's a global phenomenon like jihad or
whether it's just peculiar mental health
issues and then you and then you have a
situation where the jihad guys have got
a lot of mileage out of taking trucks
driving them up on the sidewalks killing
large numbers of people
you can't reasonably expect that just to
be confined to Muslim jihadis sooner or
later some guy like this guy with an
Armenian name and Armenia is like 99.99%
Christian apart from at least a few
years these Yazidis and Kurds I think
there's like about last time I was there
I think there were 600 Muslims in the
whole joint
but you can't expect when people see
that a car can kill large numbers of
people you
can't expect people sell well yeah but
that's just a Muslim weapon that's for
the jihad and so it eventually other
people start renting cars and driving
them up on sidewalks so but if you were
running a society wouldn't and
benefiting from it disproportionately as
our leaders do wouldn't you spend a
little bit of time thinking about how to
hold it together what makes a cohesive
successful society a society that will
for example wage a war on its own behalf
with a foreign adversary like why
wouldn't you think about that I don't
get the sense of anybody thinks about
that at all no they actually don't they
think in opposite terms in Canada
particularly you saw last year in fact
for the Dominion of Canada's a hundred
and fiftieth birthday Justin Trudeau
celebrated it by awarding ten million
dollars to a jihadist he'd had sprung
from Gitmo who killed an American over
in Afghanistan in other words
multiculturalism lets you decide which
side of the war you want to be on
whether you want to be on the home team
or the away team that's how that's how
good multiculturalism is you talked
about how they use these incidents to
take away our rights yes in the son
sense Tucker it's actually more it's
more basic than that even I mean sending
the rights to one side I notice now when
you're in London when you're in Berlin
when you're in Brussels when you're in
Paris and now presumably when you're in
Toronto they're trying to put bollards
over every strip of raised pavement so
that cars can't get up onto the sidewalk
to kill people so the price we pay in
effect for not having bollards around
the national border is we now got an
ugly up all our cities and habits all
odds'
around everything in sight on the new
york bike path for example
everywhere you go around any western
city now they're looking uglier and
uglier
because our leaders have innocents
established ugliness as the organizing
principle of the multicultural city in
the 21st century that's that's right
this is
happens you put security consultants in
charge of hardening the target rather
than right having enlightened leaders
think deeply about what it means to have
a happy cohesive society I'd like us to
soften the target and that involves
thinking about these issues in a bigger
picture sense not just bollards round
everything in sight that's exactly right
Mark Steyn thank you that was deep and
interesting